hey partner haven't you heard Cowboys
are in and no I'm not talking about the
latest open world Western behemoth I'm
talking about ash the leader of macri's
former deadlock gang and the latest
gunslinger hero to make her way into
overwatch if you're looking for a hero
with damaged precision and the tool to
take down even the beefiest of tanks
look no further
her main weapon and primary fire is her
trusty rifle the Viper firing from the
hip will dole out quick if slightly weak
shots it's got some good accuracy as
long as you don't go willy-nilly on the
trigger but if you're looking to get
that clean head shot you'll definitely
want to use her secondary fire she'll
scope in with her rifle sights and deal
about twice as much damage meaning that
two head shots will dispose of most of
the cast and one very important thing to
be aware of is the reload speed the
Viper has the slowest reload in the
entire game with a shoving each of the
12 rounds into the gun one at a time so
make sure you constantly reload or at
the very least find a quiet spot to fill
your gun back up if you do get ambushed
though ash can still escape with our
coach gun ability she'll pull out a
shotgun from her holster and fire it
knocking anyone in front of you back and
launching yourself backwards as well
just as Einstein intended you can also
use it to gain a little bit of speed or
to propel yourself onto ledges by
shooting at a wall or floor this gives
ash some very welcome mobility as well
as a quick and easy way of setting up
shop on high ground but just keep in
mind the Coach gun does deal about 90
damage at point-blank range so don't be
afraid to fire it off in someone's face
or to detonate her other ability
dynamite
yep no frills or fancy names here ash
Chuck's a bundle of explosives that in
all honesty wise a lot further than I
would have expected after a couple
seconds the fuse will burn through and
the dynamite will explode causing up to
75 damage in the surrounding area as
well as burning anyone who happens to be
standing nearby for another hundred
damage but if you're one of those
impatient types who needs to blow things
up right away you can actually shoot the
dynamite while it's still in the air
this can catch opponents off guard and
have them running further healers crying
for help as they burn now if you toss
the dynamite a short distance you can
actually detonate it with your coach gun
if you're willing to blow the cooldown
but otherwise you're gonna have to be a
crack shot with your rifle in order to
make it work
finally ash chops off their abilities
with perhaps the most friendly ultimate
in the game when activated she'll call
down haraam Nick buddy Bob to help the
team out Bob will crash land and run
straight for where you're aiming
uppercutting enemies into the air if
they get in his way once he hits a wall
or travels far enough he'll stop and
start shooting his wrist guns like a
turret but he's nothing like torrents
baby he functions very much like a
separate character he can be healed
boosted slept hacked he could push the
payload or capture point he'll even wave
at you when you greet him all this while
dealing some crazy damage and at 1200
health being an absolute beefcake of Nam
Nick after 10 seconds though he's gone
so make sure to get your hellos in while
you still can
ash is definitely here oh that requires
some practice to get just right but I
think your kit is the right mix of
damage utility and straight-up fun that
really anyone can enjoy playing her she
works best at mid to long range sneaking
people from afar and then creating traps
with her dynamite and he enclosed areas
or nail pass will be a haven for you to
toss her explosives into but try not to
get too close as her coach gun only
provides a marginal amount of protection
against quicker heroes like Genji or
tracer mainly you're gonna want to stick
close to your teammates especially
anyone with a shield picking people off
from a distance and occasionally
venturing often to high ground for a
better vantage point
while ash Canton rapid-fire her rifle
while aiming down sights one thing that
you can do for some good burst damage is
fire a shot unscoped
and then immediately scope in for a
headshot and that's a good 200 damage
right there and while it may seem that
ash might possibly take some play time
away from heroes like soldier 76 Widow
and funny enough McCree I feel like
she'll settle into the meta of quite
nicely she and Bob in fact do something
they bring some fresh and fun mechanics
to the trusty sniper class thanks for
watching everyone I hope you found this
guide helpful though there will still be
a lot more to figure out with ash as
time goes on like figuring out matchups
with other heroes finding the best spots
on maps that sort of thing our list of
hero guides is constantly growing so
don't forget we've got 28 other
characters to brush up on I'll see you
all when hero 30 drops